elles ont dansé chanté sous la pluie
cesse comédienne noir réunis ce 16 mai
en haut des marches non pas pour
défendre un film mais pour combattre les
clichés racistes dans le cinéma noir a
illuminé le tapis rouge nous sommes là
il va falloir faire avec
on aimerait que le métier comprennent
que c'est terminé et les rôles clichés
c'est terminé et mauvaise distribution
la modeste considération et surtout il
faut s'activer parce qu'on est vraiment
à la traîne
la journée a commencé tôt sur la
croisette débat et pose devant les
photographes
la comédienne aïssa maïga se plie aux
codes du festival les interviews
s'enchaînent c'est elle qui a pris
l'initiative d'un ouvrage collectif
témoignages de ses actrices noir sur les
préjugés racistes qu'elles ont toutes
vécu
j'avais joué dans un film et j'avais
réussi enfin alléluia a décroché le rôle
d'une fille une fille qui était en
couple et c'était une comédie romantique
et puis le tournage s'est bien passé
tout s'est très bien passé
et puis au moment où le film allait
sortir j'ai découvert l'affiché je
n'étais pas sur la fiche la comédienne
ayez haïdara elle rêve d'être une
actrice banale qui pourraient tous jouer
même le répertoire classique mais ça
c'est fermé pour moi mais pourtant moi
j'ai été à l'école en france juge
française et donc les classiques la
langue
celle de molière celle des alexandrins
ça fait partie de ma culture à moi mais
dans le cinéma français la diversité
peut mieux faire sur les 2617 rôle l'an
dernier seulement 171 pour des comédiens
noirs dont 31 rôles principaux
derrière la joyeuse mobilisation des
comédiennes à cannes une certitude le
chemin sera long pour que le grand écran
représente toute la société française